what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation the time has come to enter
the ring for creed
3. I am joined by the guy who watched
The Last of Us with him wah he only
watched Creed One and Two For the First
Time like yesterday
right that's right
yeah yeah he's not in this let's not
supposed to be mindful this is Andrew
Gordon eight or seven eleven thanks for
being back here you little buff man over
here are you excited I'm very pumped I
loved Creed one and two so I'm really
looking forward to this one he's the
only one who hasn't seen Creed 3 in the
theaters John I didn't know until last
week he saw this in the theaters
apparently I don't ask people to not go
to the theaters I take that burden on
myself if I want to do a movie reaction
here and I got really lucky with this
guy having that secret one or two so
here we are guys you know what to do
ding ding that like button I understood
that reference also full-length stretch
and watch songs where you sync up with
your own copy of Crete three available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page thank you to all who have joined
and we cover so many things over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included enough beating
around the bush let's see what all the
hype is about oh my God laughs
try not to laugh at that but I couldn't
open you gotta he understood
[Music]
oh I see anime in the background
apparently Michael B Jordan wanted to
make sure they put anime because of this
big thing in his childhood
[Music]
pretty sure that's not root too there's
the root yeah there's my boy Naruto
[Music]
oh that must be young Jonathan Majors
what's wrong without you
come on bro
it is not safe to be in a car with
Jonathan Majors oh God
that should be expecting this
ooh I love that lighting transition from
yellow to like dark Beyond blue
how y'all doing today
got plenty of time for that
trust
that dude really does look like a young
Jonathan major I was thinking that yeah
dude they go way back yeah
you mean you don't have one not that I
know of
you check me
whoa that's a cool shot
damn
damn and that hurt me
good transition but when you playing
nicely I got some too
so worried they're gonna get pulled over
with that gun it's original
all that
that is not a good diet for being a
boxer yes like the exact opposite oh
let me do it
oh I'm supposed to know
oh a little Donny
wow that was a cool transition this
guy's got a grip on transitions rival
and what krita said Pretty Ricky conlon
I thought he retired
impressive combo is this is rematch yeah
I guess so yeah
the moment is getting to Creed here
[Applause]
don't be caught in the past man
nice nice found an opener
damn
dude these are cool shots dude I'm
really impressed with his Direction so
far
but you're smiling for a dog he over
there beating you worse than last time
like it's something I missed
[Applause]
holy crap
ouch
awesome damn
whoa wow
oh
knock out from the body oh my God there
is so much Exquisite style to the
fighting
[Applause]
what a chest
without a dream damn in round two on the
rematch that's crazy you have no more
enemies now Donnie
it's so cute
laughs
that's a good dad
that's cool they got a studio in their
house
Shack jersey in the background yes I
know you know that who he is yeah Kazam
take that off
oh I see what you're trying to do
trying to get me naked oh no Mom yes
okay I just I have like about 15 minutes
a dude in three just watching you two
[Laughter]
we need a new badge you've
I guess he's gonna fight Ivan Drago I
mean uh Victor Victor yeah you gotta be
ready to fight dragon in four weeks wow
we know you got power but it's not
always about how hard you can hit it's
about control Focus how hard you can get
back
yeah the quote it's about how hard you
can get hit and keep moving forward how
much you can take and keep moving
forward that's how winning is done
Jacob's got a bigger name that's true
but Felix got the belt
I don't care if they don't like it whoa
tell Dragon to call me
as a nice vehicle it's worth at least
thirty thousand dollars J yeah times ten
yo remember me huh
come a long way from bummer rides from
your mom
damn
time to get some grip
thank you
Adonis does not watch what he eats hey
you do not get a boxer's body like this
I know he's in retirement but still the
shape he's in yeah road trip few times
you did where'd you send them I'm crazy
ah she's still looking better yeah she's
still there same house but I never got
him how dare she yeah that wasn't cool
but I understand why he'll be your big
head back up
remember that
you got work
I got plans
what are these plans what's the plan
same program last time you saw me
I want to be champ
you're still in the box hey I know I've
been away a long time although I kept
myself in shape you know I got some
moves you ain't seen yet yeah
doesn't believe all right
come by the gym get you set up with Duke
all right then
he is a great actor though
Jonathan Majors yeah he is he's great
oh my goodness how you feeling mama you
good it'd be better if my son showed up
on time for dinner uh sorry I just got
caught up with an old friend that you
hid the letters from
mm-hmm
do you think they're gonna kill her off
the daughter
I have a daughter or not uh I was it's
in the back of my head I'm thinking that
could happen
and I really am fine I promise you I am
not going to have another stroke tonight
oh oh
what's up with you yeah where were you
tea
just ran into this guy named Dave
trigger word who's he
he's a beast I'm just trying to give him
a break isn't that what we do anyway no
this ain't a YMCA look around dude you
see anybody lining up and getting the
ring with Felix he's gonna no yeah
where Duke's gonna take care of you we
back to Ground Zero James gotta start
somewhere right
nice there's like a Lost Child thing
about Jonathan Major's expression Felix
me Damien
you're gonna spawn with you
you still remember how to do that yeah
I
he probably shouldn't have said that
antagonistic thing towards him
really
in class in front of the teacher whoa
whoa
has your daughter punched her in the
face
[Laughter]
what if she's someplace she's supposed
to be safe and she's not she won't know
how to protect herself get her a gun
[Music]
I know that you think that you are
protecting her baby but she has got to
know why she wants to fight not just how
to do it and the only solution to every
problem is not a punch in the face yeah
you're right and sometimes it is
that Damien
okay I see you made it all right oh yeah
I just asked him well where did black
family live at
tomorrow
hmm
nice to meet you
nice
to meet you
she says YouTube I remember when I was
first learning sign language was a
little daunting how long have you known
each other the old back way back it was
like brothers shared a room for two
years at the gym
yeah something like that
I'm gonna get her to bed okay see you
Tuesday ketchup oh invite him to the
label party
I heard that I'm invited to the labor
party
thank you so much for coming yeah no
doubt
my pleasure to meet you
so happy Tessa Thompson's getting this
much screen time maybe I can make myself
clear
I want a title shot
damn
it don't work like that feeling so cold
what he got to lose what you got to lose
what you think I could just snap my
fingers and make you a contender
overnight ain't that what happened to
you
it's like but my last name's Creed yeah
look all I'm saying bro
Apollo Creed
could take a chance on something wow
that's so cool why can't you
like I say
you know you asked me to fight Felix for
real yeah heavyweight champion of the
world with their whole lives for a shot
like that and he's not even a pro yeah
yeah why does it look like you're
sucking so considerated
I love this shot it's really interesting
the purpose that Damien serves as like a
way to confront his past keep
that's what I'm talking about get your
Championship shot
yo
[Applause]
hey what's going on out here
okay use your head leave all that other
mess outside
I told you who I wanted
oh it's just getting dark I told you
right away it was a mistake I got it you
don't
you let him come in here with a chip on
his shoulder that's exactly but don't
get quiet now dookie
damn I'm really liking this a lot feels
just different yeah very different yeah
I mean I'm definitely missing Rocky but
I mean it's it's under it's still it's
really I haven't even thought about
rookie that's funny
oh [__] see that on the mirror what did
it say on the mirror I didn't see it
Curry defeats soprino oh
oh okay
[Music]
his home looks like Rocky's from the
first movie actually yeah well I was
gonna say it looks more like uh donis's
[Music]
oh man
it's interesting like the movie Cuts
back and forth between the future he's
trying to stay on the path there but
then he's got this pass that's kind of
catching up to him that he hasn't
resolved don't worry about them so many
other things in here should be looking
at all right for you bro yeah
congrats boy
I'm gonna make sure that's the fight of
the year
why would you say that in front of him
yeah seriously yeah I guess that's what
y'all do look at him over here get his
Don King on minus thank God
that's a Rocky 5 reference curious what
happened with you too
oh you wanna know how I got locked up
yeah uh
got into a fight I have a few priors
pulled gun that didn't pop off
I ain't saying do they deserve it but
it was dude his name was Leon
the rest of it we don't leave it down
here to tell you you already said this
much yeah
whoa what oh
no we're not canceling anything oh my
God someone has to fight Felix I know I
know I know but we'll figure it out do
not move the date
it on oh wow
I was so unexpected I know where the
hell did I come from
about just finding another fight I know
and I understand your frustrations I
really do so what are you gonna do maybe
two other contenders outside of Drago
this is Ortiz Nana spirino he's
recovering from his last fight okay so
then who you know who you know God damn
well who Rocky yeah what do you have in
mind he wants you to fight dang Dame
Damien ain't a boxer he's fighting the
world he's trying to hurt people no I
don't like it I think it'd be a circus
what he means is he's gonna put on a
show
exactly no it's not what we promised
okay I understand
but if it was me
I do it you think damn had anything to
do with that guy attacking Drago or was
that just random I hope for either
answer just let your boy know I'm gonna
beat his ass when I'm in that ring all I
want you to do
it's your job
I love this because you can't really
tell if Adonis is making this decision
because it's best for the show or if
it's just a personal you know uh I feel
like it I feel like it's a bit of both
because he knows they can't wait six
months but he feels like he still owes
him the future of Two fighters hangs in
the balance Creed Athletics is promoting
the most surprising fight of the year
will it be a Cinderella story or another
notch on the Champion's belt
is I want oh Staple Center nice sorry
crypto.com Arena hate that name are you
anti-American no I just hate that name I
like Staple Center better
[Music]
dude they really do a good job really
making you feel every punch yeah
especially helps when you have
headphones
I'm sorry what'd you say good in here I
know my ears are ringing from the punch
no seriously look
look lighter
thank you you ain't gotta thank me
Dan this is a fascinating story yeah it
is it really is actually yeah I don't
know the children's may look like way
more cut and dry like I'm out for you
Creed this is so much more layered and
complex wow
love it
this is Michael B Jordan's very first
film he's directed right yeah because it
doesn't feel like it feels like he's an
amateur pro at this
whoa that is cool
oh my goodness
it's like a Day of the Dead thing Dia de
los Muertos
man the theatrics of this
is the former Golden Gloves Champion
that's how Greg and I look right now I
look like that when I shave my body
I want to remind you protect yourself at
all times
I love the focus of the audio just like
zones out the crowd yeah
[Applause]
what's up
shouldn't be rooting for any of them
jab there but Anderson showing good
movement whoa
ouch
[Applause]
[Music]
oh he's just going after that shoulder
in that arm smart
he may have some tricks in his back
[Music]
there he didn't get called on it
oh LBC is that yep damn he is lethal
who's that look at his eyes man
come on
oh
I don't think it's gonna matter
this is a Fight for Your Life
oh
[__]
not to fight any of us expect
a God damn
good
this is dangerous Anderson's swinging oh
my goodness
oh
later knock out
that's the first time I cut to the mom
in this fight huh uh a second time
second time yeah because she was having
trouble with taking her medication
[Music]
that's why the mom hit the letters
oh my God Felix he's
probably gonna be paralyzed for life now
no I'm already ain't no making nothing
right ain't no Duke nothing like a fix
no
I can't he did some illegal moves though
man is the word illegal
like that was the worst I mean he did
some work moves that are like all right
I mean yeah I mean he got some point
deductions you need him in that album
yeah
[Music]
letters for you
oh dear Donny I'm going to kill you one
day
they're from Damien
oh okay Foreman Muhammad Ali kept these
from me
you didn't suspect that already I
thought you did I know I thought we'd
expect the second do you know what we
went through I know who that man was the
two of you beat up then you know Damien
had my back before you even knew who I
was
Dame treated me more like family than
your two kids ever did in this house and
you took that away from me none of this
would have happened if it wasn't for you
whoa
you're absolutely right
none of it
she's gonna have a stroke On Cue it may
have been a time when Damien had your
back
he's manipulating
oh that letter says I'm coming for you
oh is it the guy who uh broke Victor's
uh hand yeah so yeah I was gonna say
that was too rant that was too damn
random to happen I suspected it but I
was like he could he doesn't have the
money to hire a guy because yeah that's
the only thing I threw a
threw a wrench in that you've been
playing me this whole time
I brought you into my home bro you met
my family
the dark side gonna come out no when I
got locked up I leave when I came home
yeah bro
I needed you look around bro
run away
run away as to what I think you're still
good at baby Creed
oh oh call them baby crude come on man
this title oh this I'm coming for it all
and what's that supposed to mean
you threatening me
oh God damn it dude help yourself up for
once
she already feel
damn
oh [__] dude
you trying to feel sorry for me or
something I don't want to feel sorry for
you I want to understand you I want to
know what is going on
I don't want to talk about anything
I've been trying to forget it
it's Dad leave it leave it let it ride
I'm talking about that [__] no more
Heaven is her seeing you like this
do you understand I was such a
well-acted scene I know this one's there
was so so much darker than the previous
ones
just a little bit
you know it's a closed set when you
leave a Rolls-Royce with your window
halfway down
visiting world of the spot yeah oh okay
so the guy abused
physically abused them
but you know what it is huh
damn oh that sucks
that that is complicated as [__]
yeah it's not the way it looks you
better get here right away mom had
another stroke oh no
I can't remember every time I say
goodbye
I'm sorry
oh I think this is his fault he was so
mad
come knock everybody out what
just like your father
that's why he fought so hard you know
that right you don't have to do that
you can find another way
I was angry I was so angry when you left
me Apollo
whoa
did you leave me alone
I've done this
his name wow
he saved me Apollo
he helped me to forgive you
[Music]
time I see this in a movie it hits me 20
times harder
understandable you have got to try to
forgive yourself so that you can begin
to believe that you deserve the life
that you have
you have to let him destroy everything
you've built Jesus he's not gonna stop
then you make him there's only one way
the damn's gonna listen you gotta pound
his face
if that's what you gotta do then oh man
oh [__] I was not expecting that answer
there's one thing I want you to do for
me
when
when the one and only Adonis Creed is
sitting right next to me Stephen A Smith
wow he's on first take I know you watch
the show every morning yeah definitely
he questions Amanda he talks about your
family he talks about how you can't be
trusted and that you don't run out on
your boat no no no wait dude let me just
hold on hold on we got a call come in uh
I'm just telling everybody who you
really are are you running our own
family this ain't the way to handle it
oh bad news bro this live so I mean this
is how we gonna handle it now I love how
they verified it was him through the
phone I know everybody else knew it hey
uh Apollo Creed will be shame God damn
it
all right I challenge you for the
heavyweight championship of the world oh
my God y'all heard it here first I know
I can't wait I didn't see that coming
trading monsters
Greg and I actually hit the gym right
before we watched this we wanted to get
in character
[Applause]
you don't got it no more he retired he
probably won't even make weight and
remind me how many concussions have you
had
reminds me when his dad said the same
thing to uh Rocky and Rocky Balboa we
can't turn back the clock we can't hide
all your flaws but we can't make them
strips
[Music]
[Applause]
um
damn's working out in public
oh we got the vest on that thing is
heavy
hello
that would be so scary partner yeah
seriously even with that head gear on
you gotta block out everything and be in
the moment not to pass
not the future right now it's gonna be a
mental battle as well as a physical for
him
good enough to be to you
what I did not see this go back surely I
didn't either
he's not in boxing shape anymore
heart soul it crumbs
[Music]
back get back
Russian twists
oh
look Howard shape these guys are what's
the food they eat sure
all this fries
[Music]
I hope he punches that tree down oh God
oh damn
dude I would have loved to see if this
was their actual training regimen for
the movie
oh my God
goals one day they can see each other
that's the only person he's battling the
other guy is in the way I get it it's a
reference to Creed one
[Music]
I love it eat it up
[Applause]
foreign
oh my God this fight's going to be
insane
[Applause]
dude he is in Insanity shape one of his
abs equals my bicep
Maybe
oh zoning at the audio again
this symbolism on those gloves kind of
look like something from Naruto actually
it's gonna be a mental battle
[Music]
damn there's great camera work in this
yeah
whoa
[Applause]
nicely done
[Music]
I'll see you in a minute don't worry
I'll be right back
that was great
let's see if Adonis can find his answers
damn the camera work is phenomenal
stop running Tony
give him up keep them up you got old man
can't beat me heads up
oh [__] whoa
[Applause]
that was sick are they hit each other in
their clothes that was that was awesome
that was awesome I do see in just alone
the way the camera work is and capturing
the punches that I think it's in my
anime Flare from it
wow
that's interesting
[Music]
that is so
wow what
what
oh even the music choice
oh
dude the visual style and the artistic
choices brilliant bold
[Music]
oh boy
wow transitioned into a POV yeah the
cinematography is amazing
wow
[Music]
oh
wow what a transition with everyone in
the crowd too wow I've never seen
anything like that in Rocky or Creed
that was crazy I need you to start
fighting
go out there and do
it you know I wore a Naruto shirt
because I heard he's a Naruto fan but
this fight reminds me of like these two
characters from their Sasuke and Naruto
thank you
[Applause]
what the [__] man
oh
damn
you all right you all right
hmm
come on
oh nice
[__] all right
this down
the rocky sprinkled in yeah
I'm sorry
all those years
never checked up on you that's on me
we were just
kids bro didn't need to fight him in
order to get him to listen
you get a handshake
that's how we do it that was better
[Music]
I always wanted to be a baseball player
that's exactly what he was thinking
all right let's get to the mid credit
scene the post-credits I don't know
oh Ryan cougar wrote the story out okay
cool uh Sylvester Stallone
Sylvester Stallone loves you dude
wiggler
well [__] let's talk about it Andy all
right guys well everything was good
about that movie except for Jonathan
majors and Michael B Jordan's Direction
other than that the rest of the movie
was good
[Music]
I wonder whose honest opinion is that
that would be funny to hear
um no I like I really I really liked it
I wanna there's I there's some cons that
I think well my
subjective cons I know this franchise
I've seen every one of them I grew up
especially on the rocky films and
weirdly I didn't and I heard a few
people say
that they they would wonder where Rocky
is
and I wasn't really thinking about that
until a certain point in the movie I
know exactly what you're talking about
what point what point was it do you
think I'd say like once after the mother
passed and then we started ramping up
into the training montage yeah is that
when you were kind of that's when I was
like how come there's no like I think a
question I don't even need Rocky to
still show up in this movie just like
just a mention of him kind of thing
right and one mention of what's going on
with Rocky I will say this look I I
would have loved full for Sylvester
Stallone to be in this film thank you
Irwin Winkler is that he said or is it
Irvin whatever we don't need to respect
Winkler we just watch the movie yeah
whatever the case I I would have loved
for Sylvester to be in the film or rocky
rather having said that I thought Creed
2 really wrapped up Rocky's story very
beautifully so I understand
I mean I don't understand what ever
happened behind the scenes but I mean I
get it but I agree with you I would have
appreciated it just just a mention or a
comment would have been nice but I mean
there were definitely points where I was
just thinking about him not saying like
I wish he was here I could I do but you
know what I mean like I it wasn't
affecting the storyline is what I was
trying to say but I just would have
loved to have been there because I love
Rocky so I mean from that perspective
but overall I really did enjoy this
movie I you know everyone's always gonna
ask well is it the best of the Creed
films you know that's all subjective uh
I definitely would say the first one is
still probably my favorite but I still
really enjoyed this I was really
impressed with Michael B Jordan I mean
this is his film debut behind the you
know directing so I was really impressed
there were a lot of artistic stylistic
choices when it came to a cinematography
perspective and there were a lot of
well-acted scenes I mean the scenes with
him and Tessa Thompson with Bianca I
mean those scenes were extremely not
only were they just well acted but I
thought too from a story perspective
which Ryan cooler and whoever the other
writers were a great job I thought they
did just it just laid the foundation of
hey he really leans on Bianca like she
is his Rock like whenever he's lost like
I mean even you know when he's enjoying
life and doing it he obviously you know
she she's his his wife and he loves her
and all that but when he's down and the
chips are down for him like she is his
Rock and I love how they really like
hammered that through throughout the
film and come on Rock come on you set me
a [__] oh Jesus Christ that's true that
wasn't even trying to make that fun but
no it's a good that's a good uh astute
observation my friend but I thought
Tessa I mean obviously look we'll get
into Jonathan majors and Michael B
Jordan their performances were terrific
in this film but I think Tessa Thompson
like I was not expecting you made the
comment through uh during the reaction
like I wasn't expect I knew she was
going to be in the film I wasn't
expecting the role to be as big as it
was but I'm glad it was because she was
fantastic and I really like her
character and just in general from the
first two films so I'm glad they
expanded upon it expanded upon her role
rather but and fleshed her out a little
bit more with in the relationship she
has with uh Adonis but yeah no I
Jonathan Majors look regardless of what
we think about what's going on
um in his personal life acting wise he
is fantastic in this I love the way they
flesh out his character and again in the
first two films I mean look when it
comes to Pretty Ricky conlon
we don't really know too much about his
backstory other than he's about to
retire so you don't get too much in
depth with his character when it comes
to Victor Drago we obviously know the
history of with his dad and and Rocky
and Rocky 4 so we lay it's more of a
foundation there and just
The Fallout of what's happened from that
film so again you get a little bit into
his backstory but obviously with Dave
with Dame you get way more and I really
thought it was compelled like the first
two thirds of this film
I loved what they said I mean this was a
really dark dramatic character study and
I thought it was very well done and then
it really switched up a little bit but I
mean again the first two thirds of this
film chef's kiss it was fantastic
which is him what'd you think I I agree
with everything you said we should talk
about the Jonathan major situation
[Laughter]
yeah
um no no I I do agree with what you said
like I I the reason I didn't think about
Rocky until you said something in the in
the movie and and right but I was so
into the dark Drama character study and
how nuanced that was and what a
complicated situation that must be like
it really it was really interesting to
see a man like Adonis Creed
seem so focused then like this man
Adonis Creed who had this this all this
fortune and success and this and and a
newly established Legacy that's outside
of the name Apollo Creed
and just trying to keep moving forward
but then having this this chip on his
back this thing that is not only just oh
I have an unresolved thing with a former
person it's that person brings back all
kinds of memories of a whole life that
he had that is catching up to him
and that darkness that he's been just
trying to push away and I love the idea
of how the what Adonis has to deal with
is he needs to just
not just confront his feelings but learn
some like vulnerability like that's such
a big part of the movie is I need to
learn to talk
about my feelings or else the it's going
to consume me and it's going to come out
of me and it's going to cause me to make
some bad decisions
so that's why I loved the moment when he
does decide to let Dame fight the
champion because it does have me in the
audience going is this for best for the
show or is this best because or is he
just doing this because it's a it's a
personal thing he's getting his feelings
are getting too involved in the matter
so I really love that and I think
Jonathan majors in him having having
such a complicated passive and I love
how it wasn't just Jonathan Majors as uh
you know young Dame shot the guy I love
how they didn't go down with that yeah
he was just protecting him you know
absolutely and that makes it even more
complicated for the fact that Adonis
just didn't try to visit him or anything
like that
so the guilt that would weigh over him
over such a thing makes a lot of sense
but you know bringing it back to the
what I loved about the ending moments
was it brought it back to what made
those first two thirds great and like
don't get me wrong I think the final
fight is is impressively shot great like
that final fight was uh I think the
final fight is
especially as a fan of of the Rocky
movies which usually have
especially by the time we got to Rocky
of Balboa they get to a moment where
like you feel like you're just watching
a real boxing matches yeah and and often
times like as theatrical as they are the
amount of like head counts they get the
a big part of the of the experience I
think of Rocky in the Korean movies is
getting to that final fight where you
feel like you're in your protagonist
shoes and every time they get hit you
feel the hit you know
and and I thought what Michael B Jordan
decided to do with going with a with a
much more expressive route that was
clearly riffing on a lot of the um
animation influences that he grew up on
and there are part like I heard what I
heard before was that he was a big fan
of of Naruto so or something about I
heard something about Naruto while he
was promoting this and so I was like
today honor whatever the hell was going
out there and there was a fight and
there is a thing in the fight especially
when they're seeing like the childhood
versions of themselves because this is
dealing so much with unresolved past
their children and reminds me of a
couple of the characters in there it's a
great show by the way I still haven't
finished it but it's a great show but
still it's forever episodes but it's but
uh but I'm very very deep into it I only
got like 50 more to 100 episodes ago
I'm like like a thousand episodes in or
something it's a it's a great show
um so yeah I thought that was excellent
uh but the the Bane the main criticism I
have is that after the the mom dies and
around the time when the mom was even
dying it started feeling like we're
moving through this a little quick I
know it was very emotional for you
understandably why
um I I get it no jokes will be made
about that don't worry I'll watch myself
on that I will not make fun of your
traumatic past thank you appreciate it
because I'm a good guy
so I will not go there even though I can
relate
so I feel like that kind of gives me a
pass where we could make a dark joke
but I don't see an opening here
but anyway it does
first it's like this own complex drama
of these two and this big manipulation
game where yeah there's a there's this
Ferocious Beast and then Jonathan major
is given his excellent performance but I
love the complexities of them and then
suddenly it becomes
we're going to do a really short Rocky
movie by the beat you know of like I'm
gonna fight you in the ring let's go and
then it just like we start moving
through it so quick to the point where
as impressive visually as I thought the
fight was
it did not give me as a viewer like
there were some exciting moments for
sure and I wasn't I was in awe of how it
looked it did not personally give me the
experience the catharsis experience that
you usually get in the Rocky and Creed
movies by the time you get to that final
fight you know what I'm talking about so
I I don't know if you had it I was more
like I'm very appreciative of what I'm
watching and I'm really an admiration of
it it looks great and this is different
and cool about it emotionally I wasn't
as connected to that fight only because
of how I felt like we just started I
really feel like there was like a half
hour that was missing here I I was
thinking like this film really could
have benefited from another 20 to 30
minutes would have really made a again I
I still was beyond impressed the
artistic visual choices like where they
drowned out the entire crowd and the
audio was gone and you just had that
that background score and we were just
hearing you know the the punches and it
felt like it was just one-on-one them
nobody else there like I'd never seen
that in a Creed or an Iraqi film I
thought that was stylistically a very
interesting and incredible Choice by
Michael B Jordan I was I was enjoying
what I was watching but to agree with
what you're saying it just it just
really felt like we rushed to that point
from right after the mother passed away
and it's it's not like a major criticism
it's just like again you want to get
that that full feel of what you feel
when you normally watch a Rocky film or
a Creed film when we get to that final
fight and again visually we were
enjoying what we were watching was a
great fight scene for sure it's just
kind of time jumped through a lot it's
just it's just like
yeah and now we're in the ring and yeah
when so much of the stakes were were
kind of dependent on he Adonis hasn't
been fighting for years three years I
think they said right he's been yeah
like he's been out of it and um but I
still really appreciate like that really
those first two thirds are just so
strong to me it was unbelievable I love
those first two thirds and I like the
last third it is where I would say
because those first two thirds were I
wasn't thinking about Rockets I'm like
this is a very cool direction to take it
where it feels very personal and
intimate and it's like the movie has
heart but not heart in the way of how
you normally associate heart for the
rocky franchise like there's hard in the
sense of you got the family and you got
the support but they really lean more
into the the traumatic dark wounds that
these characters have and I appreciated
them going down that route because it it
made the the reason for fighting feel
very different and and I love the ending
notes as well so yeah I mean I think
like all the performances are great I
think their direction is great I think
the music is good uh I I think see the
thing is I'm not I'm not sliding with
the part that's missing like it would
have made that finale so much better
it's added to it because it's just like
we're doing we're like
it's like a Ryan coogler movie and then
suddenly it's just like a [__] speed
through this Rocky movie where there
were things that were there could have
been more moments that you really felt
for it in the build up and and I think I
feel like probably there was a longer
cut and Michael B Jordan was forced to
cut it down because the movie's already
bordering on two hours yeah no I mean
and I remember thinking the first two
thirds like wow this is so different
from anything I've seen in a Creed or a
Rocky film it but I was loving it
because it was so compelling what they
were doing and then it just jumped right
into a Rocky film which is fine you can
go into a I mean it's in the rocket
franchise so I mean I get it but from
what we had gotten in the first two
thirds to then jumping right into that
but rushing into it I agree with you I
feel like there was something that was
and again
we're not saying we didn't we we loved
this movie but I think like had you had
what Greg is talking about it would have
made a good movie a phenomenal
phenomenal movie
um so I yeah I get it and I was thinking
the same thing as it was unfolding I was
like wow we are really going into this
quickly here at the end because again
the first two thirds I I I really was
not expect I mean I'd seen the trailers
so I mean I knew a little bit about what
to expect but I just was not expecting
like a deep complex dramatic character
study what we were getting and it was
just so interesting and well told and
like you said earlier too I was so glad
when um Dame pulled that gun I'm so glad
they didn't actually go the route of him
shooting just more of just defending his
friend and just like get off of him type
thing and was just wrong situate bad
timing wrong situation when the cops
pulled up and yeah it just adds a
different type of layer to the character
where you just you even though the
character is is is a beast or John the
majors character of Dame is is a total
beast and can be a little bit of a dick
at times
you really feel you know empathetic or
sympathetic towards the character for
what happened because again he was just
defending his friend yeah and then
obviously you know there's the history
of well Adonis didn't visit him at all
and didn't write him back obviously that
was obviously his mom hit the letters
from him but
I mean yeah there was a lot of baggage
there and again I just thought the way
the characters for the most part were
fleshed out and the backstory is just it
was really well done I love seeing
everything with Amara as well yes I'm
really glad they they lean more into
that relationship
and yeah having that because you know
especially if you compare to like a
Rocky and Adrian which rarely goes to
like Rocky Force when they went through
Rocky three and four they go through
some dark [__] they always have like a
fight in something but but it never goes
that dark where it's like this is some
real dark [__] that they're going
through you know and I loved I loved the
chemistry and the and the fleshing out
of the relationship and and I really
appreciate as the as a Cree trilogy
how much of an evolution
like you get very different types of
Dynamics
I mean she's not as strongly prevalent
and Creed too like she's there but
you know like it she was just like the
wife you know
um but at least that's what I remember I
don't remember fiance yeah oh she's just
a fiance in the second one yeah he can
get he proposed her in the second one at
the beginning I don't I don't remember
them actually getting I know I just
rewatched it but I don't remember seeing
them actually get married unless there
was a time Jump and I just it went over
my head but oh interesting okay well
there was there was either way but I
love the evolution of that I think
Michael B Jordan knows his character in
and out of the one where he can direct
and do it and even on the dramatic like
having him behind the camera I think and
then actually removing Rocky gives the
Creed World a little bit of benefits to
let other people like Duke Duke Jr get
it more of a chance to shine it allows
them even more scenes probably for for
Tessa Thompson because we're not having
the Rocky Relationships so I think
removing him does help and I feel like
this did show like oh you can't continue
this without him as weird as it is to
say that I feel like you you can do it
and introducing the Jonathan Majors
character and and I feel like we are
kind of done with the Creed story at
this point yeah but it does also set it
up in a way where you know the Jonathan
Majors character had more story and you
know back to the things that I to be a
little bit more specific of what what I
think we're sort of craving because I
feel like it was kind of General about
it you know when they're saying you know
game is out there [__] talking and you
know challenging this in your man I'm
like we should see that we should see
that that trajectory of how he's rising
up in the boxing league and all the [__]
talking that he's doing and then
watching the build up to it
um because you spend so much with it
with it not building up to them fighting
you just kind of know they're gonna
fight only because it's a Korean movie
so you know eventually they're gonna
fight
but it was it's not until like an hour
in when the switch happens when you see
you know Jonathan majors and that
confrontation on the beach yeah and I
think there there should have been a
little bit more of a build up to it but
other than that I I I I have mad respect
for the fact that this went a different
way and did not feel like a formulaic
like that's that's kind of where Cree
too fell in for me where I really love
Creed one I like Creed 2 but for the
most part it was like yeah this is like
a rocky three and four it's like a Rocky
movie and this didn't feel that way and
I really loved it as someone who's a big
fan of the friend this franchise I
really loved how they took a different
way that was still very compelling
um and a little harsh I thought I
thought this was a little harsh and I
love that so overall yeah I appreciated
the movie a lot I liked it a lot I would
get I would give it like uh
beat beat boxing gloves and 80
85 actually I'll give it like an 85.
pretty close
to the Rotten Tomatoes what's Rotten
Tomatoes it got an 89 from the critics
okay I got a 96 from the fans nice I'm
an 85. all right
um it's good to hear back to the future
came out there your commando some other
good films what would you give it uh
probably go like 87 88 something like
that there you go that's why we have a
percentage thing instead of an eight out
of ten thing get some wiggle room here
8.7
but uh really quickly last thing I just
want to say if they did have rocky in
this film I thought possibly again
before seeing that he was not on the
IMDb list I thought maybe they were
going to go the route if he actually
does pass away and how that affects
Adonis um I thought maybe they were
going to go that route but obviously the
whole drama that was behind the scenes
um but again I I thought what happened
with the mother and all that was really
compelling and pushing the the story
forward and with Adonis and all that so
yeah and that's another thing too is
like without having Rocky we we get a
chance for that more that relationship
to shine I do think that not having
Rocky actually helped uh for a lot of it
at the same time there is that lingering
question of why isn't anyone
acknowledging like where is like what's
going on Rocky
in this movie because what happened at
the end of two he went to see Robert and
his grandson where were they living I
think I thought it was Canada I don't
remember I I don't know but yeah maybe
he's living with them now who knows
or he's still running Adrian's in
Philadelphia because yeah rocky rocky
was such a big part of his life of this
whole career that is not gonna think
about it it does it does make you go you
think there will be like a phone call or
something if Rocky's still alive you
know yeah well Sylvester said he's never
gonna watch this movie ever
uh I mean it it it it goes down such a
dark like the first two thirds of this I
think are so fantastic much they're
they're fantastic but they're so it's
much darker than anything before
absolutely and I and I don't feel like
that's the association that Rocky that's
that Sylvester Stallone likes would want
for this franchise
because the other ones do always have
like even though Creed one and two are
are darker than like your Rocky movies
the inspiring there's there is still
that rousing of the spirit to Vibe you
know and that that certain kind of heart
where this one does not quite do that
and I get where Sylvester's coming from
but I appreciate that I appreciated that
about this film it was different but it
was still compelling different but this
is from the guy who I mean it's funny to
hear because like he still he has the
Rambo franchise which is like so dark
I've actually never seen those movies oh
my God Andrew they're the best I love
every one of them but yeah guys what do
you think about Cree 3 do you love it is
it your favorite was it the most
crowd-pleasing entertainment source of
your life and how much do you disagree
with everything we said let us know uh
yeah let us know subscribe leave a like
all we can do is be honest still really
like the fighting and stuff but hey
let's end this with a
Michael B guess what you picked the
right guy you know why why this is the
honestly got truth Michael B the day
we're shooting this he uploaded his
movie reaction for Creed Three oh
perfect timing so guys Michael B Omni
media who has guessed it on this Chanel
and yeah what are the I didn't even put
that together Michael B yeah what are
the odds um Omni media go watch I
haven't seen his reaction yet obviously
but I'm sure it's good he did the road
to Crete three he watched he did a
reaction all the Rocky movies then Creed
movies Landing him at Creed Three and so
I do want to see his reaction for it
because it's been a quite a journey one
of the best reactors out there love you
Michael I'm gonna send you a text
message right now saying I love you
show me photos of your belly I thought
he doesn't even send me messages like
that so you should feel very privileged
ever since you started going on that
freaking Channel that's true you feel
like it's interesting I have betrayed
you and your trust you need to
understand this it's gonna take time to
get over the hurt we can settle it in
the ring in the meantime I'm gonna start
messaging Michael instead of you
but don't forget I did officiate your
wedding so I got that over Michael
that's why this hurts even more what I
have to go through now we do need to go
to a boxing ring although it because of
you I'm starting to get a little more
Jack so you better be careful
it's the end of the video you might as
well give it a shot damn that's not bad
man
you're still really firm do you take
collagen what's going on I do I don't
take collagen ah so I got that over you
huh so if I take some collagen to be a
little more firm
I'll give you I just learn about what
college it is and I was like I should
take some collagen yeah peptides dude
damn that's why you're so that's why
yeah cause I got a little bit okay
whatever go watch Omni medium
foreign
[Music]